this is one of those costumes where my
grandparents will somehow find this on
the Internet and give me a call like
what are you doing with your life I love
Halloween it's my favorite holiday
Aurora doesn't like Halloween I just
like never had I like the best Halloween
experience I'm obsessed with Halloween
there's a stronger word than obsessed we
met at a Halloween party Jen's like got
a little stupid water gonna end this
giant grin on her face I was like all
right I kind of respect that so we've
only had one Halloween together I was a
diva and I was Perla de Ville and Tyler
graciously was a damaged house Dalmatian
she tells me I'm gonna wear she holds me
to just the standard of costume and I
deliver I chose Khaleesi from Game of
Thrones so Daenerys Targaryen Khaleesi
is strong powerful and assertive what
you think Sofia can identify with but
she's also pretty high-maintenance and
pretty Queenie Sofia could be those
things too it shows a Catwoman outfit
fur because I you know I'm an error
Catwoman's always trying to be sensual
and aurorus just more down-to-earth and
chill so it'd be fun to see I thought
like immediately back to which maybe was
my sexual awakening in the movie Space
Jam Lola bunny was hot cute but like
sassy had an attitude I think Jen is a
lot of those qualities
I'm nervous because I asked him for clue
and he said it's some like a character a
person he had a crush on when he was
younger he told me stories about
hoarding Victoria's Secret magazines I
think he probably chose something I
wouldn't normally dress up that I would
be up for dressing up as like an elf or
a fairy I think it's either like a
classic historical costume or it's like
Danny like Daenerys Targaryen oh my god
I think I was right is it Danny
whenever Tyler wants to make fun of me
being high maintenance he does the like
wet oh my dragons this is from what's
that movie space jams a lot of skin you
choose something sexy it's some
character from The Dark Knight which I
have not seen with Catwoman ha I'm so
slow to these things this feels pretty
fun actually there seem to be a two sets
of holes one is for my arms and the
other is for um the sides of my torso or
my boobs
I would totally rock this if I had a few
drinks
I feel pretty tough in this things might
get a little dangerous
the wig is home sorry mom and dad I
could melt a dragon in this costume
we're going for me uh I need a
basketball wow that looking to play
basketball you ballin up ah there's a
lot of holes babe oh shoot
yikes you knew that I basically just
turned her into a Playboy bunny okay it
took me a minute to figure out what this
costume was but I'm pretty excited to be
Halle Berry that's the bad captain you
are Anne Hathaway Catwoman Oh every time
you see it look at this she's ordering
me around we tie it it Sofia wore this
for too long we might be in a dangerous
situation you know none of that that
will never do it twiddle your fingers
that bad man this is catwoman with an
Aurora spittin you're aware of that
yeah great let's get ready to rumble
Halloween this year might be a little
different this was really fun I like my
costume of being a cat person woman
woman cat cat woman I'm gonna cross this
off my bucket list
try to get you a sock what do you think
David you like it right see look at this
she loves this mmm
oh my god we could do Catwoman in Batman
one year no yeah we can definitely do
that
this is where is she